now you just talk through a bit what you
do because you indefinitely assess
effectively don't you the efficiency and
effectiveness of the police in the
public interest that's right I mean what
we don't do is individual complaints and
individual individual things that go
wrong we're more interested in systemic
matters whether the police are effective
whether they're efficient whether the
public are getting the right service and
what is your assessment of that right
now then for the met in particular uh
it's in a bad place and we all know that
is well documented that public trust in
the Met is at a low ebb and we've got
the the met in quote special measures as
it sometimes calls so I think there's a
widespread recognition that there's an
awful lot to be done what's gone wrong
with them
I've in the past I've described it as
complacent as arrogant as defensive and
I think there's been a reluctance to
accept the scale of the the problems and
it's hit some lower level leadership
stuff it's basic standards sometimes uh
and it's a culture across the met and
perhaps wider policing as well that
isn't where it ought to be now of course
you you're not commenting on individual
cases rightly
um but you know I I you know just to
reflect on what we've seen you know when
cousins are serving police officer
murdering Sarah everard David Carrick
another serving police officer emitting
71 sex offenders serving police officers
taking pictures of the bodies of two
murdered sisters sharing them on
WhatsApp
um it's just it's extraordinary I kind
of feel like in any other organization
they just clear out the leadership team
like the heads would go well they have
got a new commissioner and a new top
team uh I think under the under Mark
Rowley who's taken over and his
leadership team around him it does feel
different I think they've smelt the
coffee they understand that they can't
any longer sort of write this off as a
few bad apples it's something much more
endemic than that uh they've got a long
way to go however this is not something
that you're going to turn around
overnight it's 42 000 people in the met
and what they've got to get to is just
every one of those people behaving at
all times in a way that the public could
have a right to expect now the police
are the public and the public of the
police and this is this sort of saying
that goes way back uh but we should I
think we're entitled to hold the police
to a to a higher standard than the
general public and and so particularly
in the last few months I've been
inspecting on vetting and who gets in
and misconduct procedures and they're
not tight enough it's too easy for the
wrong people to join the police and
we've made lots and lots of
recommendations that if enacted should
start to turn things around yeah on that
on vetting I was interested you said
recently your analysis showed around one
in ten officers should never have made
it through betting well that was one in
turn of the cases we looked at which
wasn't a random sample okay but it still
adds up to hundreds of people who have
joined the police in the last three
years that we don't think should have
and what just can you
see is that because they've had prime
yeah it's all of that it's prior
convictions it's linked with criminals
that are too close and not really
explained uh it's not being entirely
honest on their application it's a whole
series of things like that that we
looked at and just said this person
shouldn't have joined and these are
clear red flags right this is not giving
like a bit of a shaky answer in an
interview that's the big wave Planet
yeah big red flowers now what there
shouldn't be is a zero tolerance
approach to anybody that's got any
blemish on their record uh shouldn't
automatically be disbarred from being a
police officer that just won't be fair
but where there is a question where
there is doubt there should be measures
put in place to to monitor these people
to keep a closer eye on them and that's
not happening either and I've got to ask
you um this has been going on for a
while have you guys been doing your jobs
properly as well you know you're
supposed to be inspecting the police why
hasn't all this been raised we're not a
regulator we're an inspector and we've
been saying this for years and years and
years I think what happened last year
after the the Wayne cousins murder is
the Home Secretary then got us to look
specifically at the Mets counter
corruption vetting across policing to
tie up some of these issues now the
carrot case came out after we'd done
this inspection but if you look at our
recommendations the majority of them
were very pertinent to to the sort of
things that went wrong in Carrick so I
am quietly confident now that if all the
recommendations get enacted we're going
to change and and sweller brave men are
now commissioned me to come back to her
in April and see how all the police
forces around the country are getting on
with enacting those recommendations so
so there is a kind of weight of effort
behind this and a recognition that has
gone on too far it's got to change it's
interesting you said you have been
plugging this for a while who hasn't
been listening to you is it previous
home secretaries is it the police what
no I don't think you blame an individual
this is systemic across policing I think
policing is challenge it's got a lot to
do we're always challenging the police
what their priorities are but I think
the whole idea of just how important it
is for policing that the wrong the wrong
people don't get in and the wrong people
don't stay in has not has not quite been
recognized as being as important as it
is yeah
a good reasons it's important is public
confidence in the police and I'm
thinking you know particularly about
women and particularly women who are
reporting sexual crimes to the police as
well and you know if you look at the
statistics you know maybe they're right
to not have confidence I think it's
around one percent of reported rapes and
in a conviction I mean has very
effectively been decriminalized I think
when our report we look specifically at
police misconduct Through The Eyes of uh
of women serving and policing and while
there are plenty of women who've had
great careers and gone to the top of
policing
most of them if not all of them have had
to endure some completely unacceptable
behavior on the way there so I'm not
talking about you know
slightly rivaled comments I'm talking
about sexual assault in many cases uh
totally inappropriate behavior in the
workplace my fellow officers my fellow
officers and then being reluctant to
report it because you think you'll be
the person that's then stigmatized in
some way as a result so the culture of
misogyny within policing is something
that is there it's real and it's
absolutely got to be dealt with it's
really concerning as well isn't it
because you know if people are going to
the police for help with you know the
most sensitive things the things that
you know people feel ruin their lives
frankly and you're saying that you can't
really
necessarily trust that the person you're
dealing with is not the misogynist I
mean I think I think my my message to
the public generally would be in general
you should trust the police what I think
we're aiming for here uh is a situation
where there's it's an automatic we're
automatically assuming that we can trust
the police without having to ask these
questions I think there's a long way to
go before we're there I'm interested to
know your thoughts as well on the London
uh fire brigade I know that you look at
far Services as well an independent
report in November finding some pretty
awful examples of racism sexism and we
did speak to the uh Union Leader at the
London public AIDS uh Union as well and
he was saying look there is a failure of
leadership and we've been flagging it
for a while as well the union and
they're not doing enough uh well uh many
of the problems with the London fire
brigade are mirrored in the match we've
also actually got the London fire
brigade in quote special measures
largely as a result of of a really un
unpleasant culture that's highlighted in
the report you refer to so we get that I
think fire service is like police have
got a long way to go to reform and be
the sort of workplace that I think the
public has a right to expect and they're
a long way from it